I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi there, lady. Hey there. How's it going?
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你打造了终极的《办公室》爱好者的播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后花絮和大量闺蜜故事，带你深入了解《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妈 6.0。嗨，辣妈。嗨。最近怎么样？
It's going pretty good. Yeah? Can't complain. No complaints here either. Before we hopped on today, I was just kind of doing the scroll on the old social media. And I saw the most fun thing. You want to hear it? Yeah.
挺好的。是吗？没什么好抱怨的。我这里也没什么好抱怨的。今天开录前，我正闲着在老社交媒体上随便刷刷。然后我看到了最有趣的事。你想听听吗？好啊。
So I know you love hockey, lady. We know you love hockey. Listen, I don't just love heated rivalry. I also love hockey, period. Okay, well, listen to this. This was really, really cool. And gosh, it looks like it was a blast. And I want to share it.
我知道你喜欢冰球，辣妈。我们都知道你喜欢冰球。听着，我不只是喜欢炽热的宿敌对决。我也喜欢冰球，句号。好吧，听听这个。这个真的非常非常酷。天哪，看起来太棒了。我想分享一下。
It's already happened, but I think it's so fun. Okay. the Flyers, which I guess are the hockey team in Philadelphia, Jenna, but you probably already knew that. Yes. They had their first ever themed night celebrating the office. What? Yes. On March 14th, they were playing the Columbus Blue Jackets, and the Flyers decided to pay tribute
事情已经发生了，但我认为它非常有趣。好吧。费城飞人队，我想这是费城的一支冰球队，珍娜，但你可能已经知道了。是的。他们举办了有史以来第一个以《办公室》为主题的庆祝之夜。什么？是的。在3月14日，他们对阵哥伦布蓝衣队，飞人队决定向
to what they said was one of the most iconic TV shows to celebrate the network's 100th anniversary on NBC. and they had all of these clips from the show. You know, on the giant Jumbotron? Yeah. They played clips from the office. They had, like, themed food and beverages. And they had giveaways. And it was all the office theme.
他们所说的最具标志性的电视剧之一致敬，以庆祝该电视台在NBC成立100周年。他们播放了所有来自该剧的剪辑。你知道，在巨大的巨型超大屏幕上吗？是的。他们播放了《办公室》的剪辑。他们有，比如，主题餐饮。他们还有赠品。这全都是《办公室》主题的。
And there were surprise appearances by Leslie David Baker and Kate Flannery. They did that really fun thing where they go around the stadium, you know, and up on the Jumbotron, they played the look-alike game, where they put, like, a celebrity and then the person that looks like them in the stadium. And it was all characters of the office. But when they got to Leslie and Kate, they banned actually to them. And the place went crazy. Oh, my gosh.
还有莱斯利·大卫·贝克和凯特·弗兰纳里的惊喜客串。他们做了一件非常有趣的事，就是他们绕着体育场走，你知道的，在大屏幕上，他们玩了明星脸游戏，他们放一个名人，然后放体育场里长得像他们的人。全部都是《办公室》的角色。但是当镜头转到莱斯利和凯特时，他们实际上转到了他们身上。现场气氛瞬间疯狂。哦，天哪。
Well, I love that. You know, when I was in St. Louis a few years ago, went to a blues game with my family. And the folks at the blues knew we were going. So they did an office-themed one. And then when they flashed up a picture of Pam, then they would show me and kind of reveal that I was there. But I said, you know, it would be kind of fun. what if you show my daughter first and then I'll sit next to her and then you can pan to me because she looks like she probably looks more like Pam than I do now really yeah she's a mini you for sure yeah and so it was
嗯，我喜欢这样。你知道，几年前我在圣路易斯时，和家人一起去看了布鲁斯队的比赛。布鲁斯队的人知道我们要去。所以他们做了一个《办公室》主题的活动。然后当他们闪现帕姆的照片时，他们就会展示我，并以此揭示我在那里。但我说，你知道，这可能会很有趣。如果你先展示我女儿，然后我坐在她旁边，接着镜头再转到我身上会怎么样？因为她看起来——她现在可能比我更像帕姆，真的吗？是的，她绝对是你的迷你版。是的，所以
really cute and it's a fun family memory that's adorable I was at a Broncos game and they pan to me one time and lady I got so excited seeing myself on the Jogotron I lost all my cool I was like dancing around have you ever I've ever seen Jeff Goldblum get? Yes, I was like that. Yes, seeing himself on the Jumbotron, it's so charming. But I knew I was going to be on the Jumbotron. But it's an exciting thing. It just is.
非常可爱，这是一个有趣的家庭记忆，太可爱了。我有一次在野马队的比赛中，镜头有一次转到了我，辣妈，我在大屏幕上看到自己时太兴奋了。我完全失态了。我当时在到处跳舞，你有见过杰夫·高布伦——我有见过。是的，我就那样。是的，看到自己出现在巨型超大屏幕上，太迷人了。但我知道我会上巨型超大屏幕的。但这是一件令人兴奋的事。本来就是。
It's super exciting. And they play like the office theme music and it's just really fun. But yeah, I thought that was cool. They had an all office theme night at the Flyers game. Very cool. Well, listen, everybody, we have a really fun episode today. We are going to be playing the game, two truths. a lie with Joel McHale. We love Joel. We love Joel. He's a good friend. And I just can't wait,
超级兴奋。而且他们播放了《办公室》的主题音乐，真的非常有趣。但是，是的，我觉得这很酷。他们在飞人队的比赛中举办了全《办公室》主题之夜。非常酷。好吧，听着，各位，我们今天有一集非常有趣的节目。我们将和乔尔·麦克海尔一起玩游戏：两真一假。我们爱乔尔。我们爱乔尔。他是个好朋友。我简直等不及了，
because you never know what you're going to get with Joel. Well, first, though, we are going to do our fan chit-chat question of the week. This one is coming from Hannah P in South Carolina. Hi, office ladies. Apakabar. My name is Hannah, and I have a get-to-know-you question that's usually used in my friend group. When someone starts new at work, we ask, what's your garbage? This is usually something weird or gross or funny that you find totally normal, but other people are shocked by. For example, my favorite kind of popcorn is three days old or burnt. My mom's favorite snack, her dessert, is banana strawberry baby food, and a friend of mine would just clip her nails anywhere in her house and just clean them up next time she vacuumed. So it can be food or a habit
因为你永远不知道从乔尔那里会得到什么。不过首先，我们要进行本周的粉丝闲聊问题。这个问答来自南卡罗来纳州的汉娜·P。嗨，办公室辣妈们。你好吗？我叫汉娜，我有一个通常在我的朋友圈里使用的破冰问题。当有人在工作中有新同事入职时，我们会问：你的“垃圾”是什么？这通常是你觉得完全正常，但其他人却大跌眼镜的某种奇怪、恶心或有趣的事情。例如，我最喜欢的爆米花是存放了三天或者烤焦的。我妈妈最喜欢的零食，她的甜点，是香蕉草莓婴儿辅食，我的一个朋友会在她家里的任何地方剪指甲，然后等到下次吸尘时再清理它们。所以它可以是食物、一个习惯
or anything someone has said, that's crazy and you just don't agree. Also, I've lived in Indonesia and I'm moving back there soon, so I absolutely love hearing Angela speak Indonesian since I never get to hear it here in the States. Thanks for all you guys do. Oh, Hannah, Kabad Baik, Trimakasi. Thank you so much for writing in. And I'm so excited to hear that you're going back to Indonesia. It's such a wonderful place. That just gave me all the warm feelings, Jenna, just hearing her say, Apakabar, made my day. Well, I love that and I love Hannah's question. I love that the way they get to know each other is by leading with their garbage. I think that's very cute.
或者任何人说的话，那些很疯狂而且你完全不同意的事。另外，我曾在印度尼西亚生活过，我很快就要搬回那里去了，所以我非常喜欢听安吉拉说印尼语，因为我在美国从来没有机会听到。谢谢你们所做的一切。哦，汉娜，祝你好运，谢谢。非常感谢你来信。听到你要回印度尼西亚，我感到非常兴奋。那是一个如此美妙的地方。这给了我所有的温暖感觉，珍娜，听到她说“你好吗”，让我的一整天都变得美好了。嗯，我喜欢这个，我也喜欢汉娜的问题。我喜欢他们了解彼此的方式是从分享他们的“垃圾”开始的。我觉得这非常可爱。
I mean, Hannah, I want this to be like one of the questions when you're out of fun, like, dinner party. What's your garbage? I am going to make a mental note of that. So, and what comes to mind for you? Well, you know, Hannah gave the example of like three-day-old burnt popcorn. Here's something I like. And I don't think it's that weird. I think there's going to be people out there that do this as well.
我是说，汉娜，我希望这能成为你在有趣的晚宴上问的问题之一，比如：你的“垃圾”是什么？我要把它记在心里。那么，有什么事情会让你想起来呢？好吧，你知道，汉娜举了存放三天或烤焦的爆米花的例子。这里有我喜欢的东西。而且我不认为这有多奇怪。我想外面也会有人这样做的。
Let me know. but I love nothing more than like if we order pizza and everyone is done with their pizza. You know, our kids kind of eat the pizza, but then they don't eat the crust. And then they put it back in the pizza box. And so then I go to clean up and there's a pizza box full of a lot of crust. And I will go get some ranch dressing and I eat the pizza crust. I mean, I'm not going to, like, eat after someone I don't know, no. But you know what I mean? I'm like, we're not wasting this pizza crust, are we? I have put pizza crust in a Ziploc bag and saved it for the next day and heated it up in the microwave with some ranch dressing.
告诉我。但我最喜欢的事情莫过于，如果我们订了披萨，大家都吃完了他们的披萨。你知道，我们的孩子们把披萨吃了，但他们不吃披萨边。然后他们把它放回披萨盒里。接着我去收拾，发现披萨盒里满是披萨边。然后我会去拿一些牧场沙拉酱，吃掉那些披萨边。我是说，我可不会吃我不认识的人吃剩的东西，不。但你知道我的意思吗？我想，我们不能浪费这些披萨边，对吧？我曾把披萨边放进自封袋里，留着第二天在微波炉里加热，蘸点牧场沙拉酱吃。
Is that weird? So your garbage is that you can't let pizza crust go. I can't. I love the taste of it. I love pizza crust. I don't understand people who don't like the crust. I feel like it's all leading up to the crust. If it's a good crust, I get excited when I get to the crust. Do you ever go and take a piece of pizza crust off the pizza and then leave the pizza part and just eat the crust? I haven't done that, but I will tell you I can't wait for the pizza crust.
这很奇怪吗？所以你的“垃圾”就是你不能放过披萨边。我不能。我喜欢它的味道。我喜欢披萨边。我不理解那些不喜欢披萨边的人。我觉得所有的铺垫都是为了披萨边。如果这是一个好的披萨边，当我吃到披萨边时我会感到很兴奋。你有没有去过把披萨上的披萨边拿下来，然后把披萨的主体留着，只吃披萨边？我没有这样做过，但我会告诉你，我迫不及待地想要吃到披萨边。
Like, I kind of get through the pizza. Like, just get me through it. Just you're here for the crust. I'm here for the crust. And then I want you to know that I'm talking all crusts, deep dish crust, medium, thin crust that's like crispy. And people are like, why do you want the thin crust? I'm like, give me the crust.
就像，我差不多是把披萨吃完。就像，让我把它吃完就行。你是为了披萨边而来的。我是为了披萨边而来的。然后我想让你知道，我说的是所有的披萨边，深盘披萨边、中厚披萨边、还有烤得酥脆的薄披萨边。人们会问，你为什么想要薄披萨边？我说，把披萨边给我。
I love the crust. So that's my garbage. What about you, lady? What's your garbage? Well, my garbage is something that I feel like maybe I've shared on the podcast before, but this is what came to mind. It's very Angela Martin of me. But sometimes I get foster kittens and I lick their heads.
我爱披萨边。所以这就是我的“垃圾”。你呢，辣妈？你的“垃圾”是什么？好吧，我的“垃圾”是我觉得我以前可能在播客上分享过的事情，但这就是我脑子里想到的。这非常符合安吉拉·马丁的风格。但有时我领养小猫，我会舔它们的头。
Like where? between their eyes? Like their mama? Like their mama. Like when they first come in and they're like semi-feral and the only way you can hold them is to wrap them up like a little burrito and a blanket. And then you snug them up real close on your chest. I always pet them right there. But sometimes if they're especially scared, I might give a little lick just to try to, I don't know.
比如哪里？在它们的眼睛之间？像它们的妈妈一样？像它们的妈妈一样。就像它们刚来的时候，有点半野性，你唯一能抱它们的方法就是把它们像一个小墨西哥卷饼一样用毯子裹起来。然后你把它们紧紧地抱在胸前。我总是在那个地方抚摸它们。但有时如果它们特别害怕，我可能会舔一下，以此来，我不知道。
create that bond. You are so much more Angela Martin in this moment than I am. I know. I know. I guess my question is when you lick that little part between their eyes, do you get hair on your tongue? Are you then like, like, luk, gluck. No, you don't. You really don't. It doesn't come off. There's nothing there.
建立那种纽带。此刻你真的比我更像安吉拉·马丁。我知道。我知道。我想我的问题是，当你舔它们眼睛之间的那个小地方时，你的舌头会沾上猫毛吗？然后你会不会像这样：呸，呸。不，不会。真的不会。毛不会掉下来。上面什么都没有。
I give it a couple little licks and then I give it a little smooth with the thumb. You are a very dedicated kitty foster parent. I hope by the time this podcast comes out, I have none of them in my house anymore. Because they've all been adopted. Because they've all gone to their forever homes. But I'll let you know. I've managed to do cat rescue for 20 years without a foster fail. So I'm hoping I can keep up my record.
我轻轻舔两下，然后用大拇指顺一顺。你真是一个非常敬业的猫咪寄养家长。我希望当这个播客播出时，我家里已经一只都没有了。因为它们都被领养了。因为它们都去了它们永远的家。但我会让你知道的。我设法进行了20年的猫咪救援，却没有一次寄养失败。所以我希望我能保持我的纪录。
There's no way. You're going to end up adopting one of these. There's no way. Every single time you have a litter of kittens that you're fostering, you're like, okay, I'm going to keep one of them. The odds are not in your favor here. You are going to end up keeping one of them. This is a terrible BFF. right now. You're supposed to be like, don't worry, the right person will find them.
绝对不可能。你最后肯定会收养其中一只的。绝对不可能。每次你寄养一窝小猫时，你都会说：好吧，我要留下一只。这里的几率对你可不利。你最后肯定会留下一只的。你现在真是一个糟糕的闺蜜。你本来应该说：别担心，会有合适的人找到它们的。
No, it's not about that. Don't give into this temptation. No, it's not about that. Why is it a temptation if you make a connection with one of the kitties? Because you can't, then I can't foster another litter of kittens because I can't absorb a kitten every time. I'll be overrun. I'm just saying just one time. This is just one time. Oh my gosh. You're a rescuer's nightmare right now. This is not what I need. I'm sorry, lady. I'm so sorry. Okay. They're all going to find wonderful homes.
不，不是这样的。不要屈服于这种诱惑。不，不是这样的。如果你和其中一只小猫建立了联系，为什么这是一种诱惑？因为你不能，然后我就不能再寄养下一窝小猫了，因为我不能每次都收留一只小猫。我会应接不暇的。我只是说就一次。这只是最后一次。哦，天哪。你现在简直是动物救助者的噩梦。这不是我需要的。对不起，辣妈。非常对不起。好吧。它们都会找到美好的家的。
You're doing a great job. Way to go. So, yeah, I guess that's my garbage, is that I lick my kittens from time to time. Like Angela Martin maybe did with her garbage, her literal garbage cat. I mean, your garbage is coming from such a nurturing place. And mine is coming just from like love of bread. It feels kind of lame. Matt, what about your garbage?
你做得太棒了。加油。所以，是的，我想这就是我的“垃圾”，就是我有时会舔我的小猫。就像安吉拉·马丁对待她的“垃圾”一样，她的字面意义上的垃圾猫。我是说，你的“垃圾”来自于如此充满关爱的地方。而我的则纯粹源于对面包的热爱。这感觉有点逊。马特，你的“垃圾”是什么？
I think I'm kind of like Angela where I just, it's the eating of other people's leftovers. Now, now hold up, Matt. I am not eating other people's leftovers. I just want your pizza crust. If you and I order a pizza and you're not going to eat your crust, I'll take it. See, I'll take it a step further. And for me, it's like when my kids come home from school, I open their lunchbox, especially because it's like around that time of day.
我觉得我有点像安吉拉，我只是——就是吃别人的剩饭。等等，等等，马特。我可没有吃别人的剩饭。我只是想要你的披萨边。如果你和我点了一份披萨，而你又不打算吃你的披萨边，那我就拿走了。你看，我会更进一步。对我来说，就是当我的孩子们放学回家时，我打开他们的午餐盒，尤其是因为差不多到那个时间了。
It's like the late afternoon. Like, I'm kind of hungry. I just like, even while I'm still at, like, the school parking lot, I'll open their little, my little pony lunchbox and grab some warm chicken nuggets and, like, fruit that's been warmed by the sun. It's like a parent's afternoon snack. Yeah, I just my blood sugar's a little low. I just need a little snack. I feel worried for you. I'm worried you're going to get food poisoning. So far, so good. Okay, good. But come on. What's in a kid's lunchbox? I don't know. Some goldfish, some pretzels. So you're getting a soggy pretzel. Yeah, exactly. Jenna, Matt and I are clearly kind of laid back about food, eating other people's food.
就像是接近傍晚的时候。比如，我有点饿了。我只是觉得，甚至当我还在学校停车场的时候，我就会打开他们的小马宝莉午餐盒，抓几个温热的鸡块，还有被太阳晒温的水果。这就像是家长的下午茶点心。是的，我的血糖有点低。我只是需要一点小点心。我为你感到担心。我担心你会食物中毒。目前为止，一切都好。好吧，那就好。但拜托。小孩子的午餐盒里有什么？我不知道。一些金鱼饼干，一些蝴蝶饼。所以你吃的是受潮的蝴蝶饼。是的，完全正确。珍娜，马特和我显然对食物都挺随意的，吃别人的食物。
Oh, well, thank you so much, Hannah. We had fun sharing our garbage. And everyone, we're going to take a break. We'll be back with Joel McHale. This episode is sponsored by BetterHelp. I've been thinking a lot lately about how important it is to take care of our mental health. Not just when things feel overwhelming, but as part of everyday life, therapy, really isn't just for crisis moments. It's a tool. Yeah. I've seen how powerful it can be. But I also know that finding time for therapy can be really tricky. And that's why we love BetterHelp. Everything is online so you can schedule sessions by phone, video, or even message chat. They have the largest and most diverse network of therapists over 30,000 covering everything from anxiety and depression to stress and relationship issues. And here's the thing, if the therapist you find isn't the perfect fit for you,
哦，好吧，非常感谢你，汉娜。我们分享我们的“垃圾”玩得很开心。各位，我们要休息一下。我们稍后会回来，采访乔尔·麦克海尔。本集节目由BetterHelp赞助。最近我一直在思考照顾我们的心理健康有多么重要。不仅在事情让人感觉难以招架时，而是作为日常生活的一部分，心理治疗真的不只是危机时刻的工具。它是一种工具。是的。我见过它能产生多大的力量。但我也知道，要抽出时间进行心理治疗真的很棘手。这就是为什么我们喜欢BetterHelp。一切都在线上，因此你可以通过电话、视频甚至消息聊天来安排课程。他们拥有最大、最多样化的治疗师网络，超过30,000名治疗师，涵盖从焦虑、抑郁到压力和人际关系问题的方方面面。而且事情是这样的，如果你找到的治疗师并不完全适合你，
you can switch anytime, easily, and at no extra costs. So take a moment and prioritize your well-being with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash OfficeLadies to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash Office Ladies. Understanding power requires more than headlines. I'm Peter Hamby, host of the Powers That Be, a podcast from Pock examining politics, economics, and media to provide context, analysis, and clarity without sensationalism. We ask how power operates, who benefits, and what's at stake. If you want to move beyond breaking news to deeper understanding, join us on the Powers That Be.
你可以随时更换，操作简单且无需额外费用。所以，花点时间，通过BetterHelp优先考虑你的幸福。访问BetterHelp.com斜杠OfficeLadies，即可在你的第一个月享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp，H-E-L-P点com斜杠OfficeLadies。理解权力需要的不仅仅是头条新闻。我是彼得·汉比，来自Pock的播客《权力的本质》的主持人，该播客研究政治、经济和媒体，以提供背景、分析和清晰度，而没有耸人听闻的炒作。我们询问权力是如何运作的，谁从中受益，以及什么处于危险之中。如果你想超越突发新闻，获得更深入的理解，请加入我们的《权力的本质》。
New episodes every weekday, follow the Powers That Be wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, Joel. That's our sting, Joel. Are you so impressed? I can't believe you got Sting to do that whole sting. Wow. I'm off to a roaring start. I apologize. You stop it. Joel, how are you? Look at us, drinking, enjoy, wait, enjoying ourselves. Remember the last time I stumbled into your podcast? Yes, we do. That was pre-pendemic, right? That was pre-pandemic. That was that Earwolf. And that's when you could walk down a hallway and kind of look in the sort of sound booth windows and see who was recording and you walked by and saw us and
每个工作日都有新节目，在获取播客的任何地方关注《权力的本质》。嗨，乔尔。那是我们的音效，乔尔。你印象深刻吗？我真不敢相信你们竟然能请到斯汀来做那个音效。哇。我开局非常顺利。我道歉。你别这样。乔尔，你好吗？看看我们，在喝酒，享受，等等，在享受我们自己。还记得我上次跌跌撞撞地闯进你们的播客是什么时候吗？是的，我们记得。那是疫情前，对吧？那是疫情前。那是在Earwolf。那时候你可以走过一条走廊，透过录音棚的窗户看看是谁在录音，你走过时看到了我们，然后
you just came in. You're like, hey guys. You're like, what are you guys doing? What's happening here? You guys making a podcast? Joel, I have to brag on you a little bit, which is you've got a wicked forehand, my friend. You've got a really good forehand. I'll take that. I had to work on it. You had to work hard on it, but you've got a really nice forehand. So if you guys ever find yourself in a tennis match with Joel. Watch out for the forehand. How many times a week do you play, Joel? Every day, almost.
你就直接进来了。你就像是，嘿，伙计们。你就像是，你们在干什么？这里发生什么事了？你们在做播客吗？乔尔，我得夸夸你，就是你有一个厉害的正手，我的朋友。你的正手真的很棒。我接受。我不得不练习它。你为此付出了很多努力，但你的正手真的很漂亮。所以如果你们发现自己和乔尔打网球。小心他的正手。你一周打几次，乔尔？几乎每天。
Is that right? Yeah. Do you get out there every day? Yeah, my son plays. He's 17 and on his high school team. So that really helps. And we have a tennis court. Yes, I've done well, everyone. I just want to let people know.
是吗？对。你每天都去吗？对，我儿子打球。他17岁，在他所在的高中的校队。所以这真的很有帮助。而且我们有一个网球场。是的，我干得不错，各位。我只是想让大家知道。
That's what I spent my money on. I will say you share, though, because I do not have a tennis court, but you're like, Ange just come over. And then I come and I show up with like homemade granola. I just leave you guys granola. That's our trade.
这就是我花钱的地方。不过我要说的是，你很大方，因为我没有网球场，但你会说：安吉，过来吧。然后我就去了，带着自制格兰诺拉麦片。我把格兰诺拉麦片留给你们。这是我们的交易。
Like Sarah loves that homemade. Oh, my, she won't stop talking about it. How did they do it? It's toasty and it's so flavorful. It's salty and sweet. It's just. See, Jenna, you have this whole other world of old people hitting tennis balls and eating granola.
就像莎拉喜欢那个自制麦片。哦，天哪，她赞不绝口。他们是怎么做到的？烤得很香，而且很有风味。又咸又甜。就是。你看，珍娜，你拥有另一个老年人打网球和吃格兰诺拉麦片的世界。
Am I allowed to come over and just eat the granola? Yes. Mm-hmm. Is there a place for me? Yes. We have some benches you can watch from. Just watch for the errant line drive. Yeah.
我能过去只吃格兰诺拉麦片吗？可以。嗯哼。有我的位置吗？有。我们有一些长椅，你可以从那里观看。只要小心飞来的网球就行。还有一棵迈耶柠檬树，就在网球场旁边的柠檬是我这辈子见过最多的。
And a lemon tree that is like the most lemons I've ever seen in my life right by the tennis court. Like it's kind of nuts. It is so weighed down. It doesn't look like it's going to survive. But it's a Meyer lemon tree too. So it's. Oh, those are the best lemons. I have a Meyer lemon tree.
就像它有点疯狂。它被压得太重了。看起来都快活不成了。但它也是一棵迈耶柠檬树。所以它是。哦，那是最好的柠檬。我有一棵迈耶柠檬树。
They're sweeter. They're so good. And they're growing up. Growing up in the Northwest, thank you. Shout out to Rain Wilson. I never dreamt if you lived in Southern California. You would just plant a fruit tree and it's going to grow and just start dumping oranges everywhere. It seems like Shangri-La when you think about it that way.
它们更甜。它们太棒了。而且它们在生长。在西北部长大，谢谢。向雷恩·威尔逊致敬。我从未梦想过如果你住在南加州。你只需要种一棵果树，它就会生长，然后开始到处掉落橙子。如果你那样想的话，它看起来就像世外桃源。
Can I ask a question? Because I've wondered this. So in my neighborhood, like you said, like living in Southern California, people have fruit trees. They just have them. There's pomegranate trees and persimmon trees and so many. lemon and lime and orange trees and you just go for a walk in the neighborhood and sometimes those trees are in people's front yards and they're really full of fruit. Do you think it's okay to pick a piece of fruit off of someone else's tree that's in their front yard? Are you trespassing? Are
我可以问个问题吗？因为我一直很好奇。所以在我的社区里，就像你说的，住在南加州，人们都有果树。他们就是有。有石榴树、柿子树，还有那么多。柠檬树、青柠树和橙子树，你只要在社区里散步，有时这些树就在人们的前院里，而且果实累累。你觉得摘一颗别人前院树上的水果可以吗？你这是在擅自闯入吗？
the branches leaning over the fence? There's no fence. It's just a sidewalk and there's a tree there And maybe you're passing by and you are like, I'd love an orange. And there's so many of them. There's so many. So I'll just say, I never do it. But I feel like it should be okay. As long as you're not taking the last one or there's a dozen left. Like, how many oranges does one person need?
树枝伸过栅栏了吗？没有栅栏。只有人行道，那里有一棵树。也许你路过，然后你心想：我想要个橙子。而且它们有那么多。有那么多。所以我只想说，我从不这样做。但我觉得这应该是可以的。只要你不是拿走最后一个，或者还剩下一打。一个人需要多少个橙子？
I need them all. Do you not want anyone? You don't want anyone taking your lemons. Well, why do you think we have such a huge wall? keeping everyone separated from our lemons. Well, I have neighbors guys, and they are side by side. You know, like their driveways line up next to each other. And on one, that's how it is with my neighbor.
我全都要。你难道不希望任何人拿走你的柠檬吗？好吧，你以为我们为什么有这么高的墙？把每个人和我们的柠檬隔开。好吧，我有邻居，伙计们，他们紧挨着。你知道的，就像他们的车道并排在一起。其中一个，我的邻居就是这样。
Okay, so on one side, my neighbor has a lemon tree. It's loaded with lemons. And he has just a basket underneath it. And he's got a little sign that says, please take the lemons. You know, feel free. And then on the other driveway, just a few feet away, another lemon tree loaded with lemons, and they have a sign, do not pick the lemons. So it's like, that's not true.
好吧，所以在一边，我的邻居有一棵柠檬树。上面挂满了柠檬。他在树下放了一个篮子。他立了一个小牌子，上面写着：请拿走柠檬。你知道，请自便。然后在另一边的车道上，仅几步之遥，另一棵挂满柠檬的柠檬树，他们立了一个牌子：请勿采摘柠檬。所以就像，这不是真的。
Are you serious? It is true. It is true. I promise you. And I'm like, what? These two people have very different philosophies. They're letting the whole neighborhood know about it. Yeah. All right.
你是认真的吗？这是真的。这是真的。我向你保证。我就想，什么？这两个人有着截然不同的哲学。他们让整个社区都知道这件事。好吧。
Well, on those good vibes, I think it's time. You try to transition to this game, Angela? I'm trying. Joel, I'm trying. You should know this about me. I'm horrible at transitions and segways. Like if we're at a cocktail party and I really want to talk to you and you're talking to people and like you're standing, let's say, by a Christmas tree,
在那种良好的氛围下，我想是时候了。安吉拉，你试着过渡到这个游戏？我正在试。乔尔，我正在试。关于我，你应该知道这一点。我非常不擅长过渡和承上启下。就像如果我们在鸡尾酒会上，我真的很想跟你说话，而你正在和别人说话，而且你站着，比方说，在一棵圣诞树旁边，
I might walk up and be like, here's the thing about Christmas trees. The whole energy. That sounds like a segue into conversation, though. Yeah. I mean, if you were to launch into like, the Atlas Mountains are in Morocco. I'm like, what? Yeah. No, I just look at something right in front of me and comment.
我可能会走过去说：关于圣诞树，事情是这样的。整个能量。听起来这像是切入对话的过渡。对。我是说，如果你突然开始说：阿特拉斯山脉在摩洛哥。我会觉得：什么？对。不，我只是看着我面前的东西然后发表评论。
Okay. This is going to be the best transition. of your whole effing life. Are you ready? Now there's a lot of pressure here. You know who's so much fun at a party and who's great at playing games? It's our dear friend, Joel McHale. And we thought, who better than to play two truths and one lie with?
好吧。这将是你整个他妈的人生中最棒的过渡。准备好了吗？这里有很大的压力。你知道谁在派对上最有趣，谁最擅长玩游戏吗？是我们亲爱的朋友，乔尔·麦克海尔。我们想，还有谁比他更适合玩“两真一假”呢？
We had Creed Braton. He played it, Joel. No pressure. He is amazing at two truths and a lie. At lying and telling the truth. Uh-huh, because his truths and his lies are kind of blurry. and what we're going to need from you, Jen and I did not do a lot of Googling on you.
我们有克里德·布拉顿。他玩过，乔尔。没有压力。他在“两真一假”方面非常厉害。在说谎和说实话方面。嗯哼，因为他的真话和谎言有点模糊不清。我们需要你做的是，珍娜和我没有对你进行大量的谷歌搜索。
We wanted to be surprised here. We don't want to know all your ins and outs, okay? All your business. So we're going to need you to tell us two truths and a lie in any order. And then Jenna and I are going to guess which one is the lie. And you folks listening out there can play along with us. So, Joel, you're up. You have to tell us now.
我们想在这里感到惊讶。我们不想知道你所有的内幕，好吗？你所有的底细。所以我们需要你以任何顺序告诉我们两个真话和一个谎言。然后珍娜和我将猜出哪一个是谎言。收听节目的各位朋友也可以和我们一起玩。所以，乔尔，轮到你了。你现在必须告诉我们。
Two truths and a lie. And it can be anything. It can be anything. So it could be like, I could tell a 25-minute story. Sure. Sure. Three 25-minute stories. But you are going to have to take a break.
两真一假。而且什么都可以。什么都可以。所以这可能类似于，我可以讲一个25分钟的故事。当然。当然。三个25分钟的故事。但你得休息一下。
And one of them is a lie. You will have to pause because I'm going to have to go pee if you do three 25-minute stories. I will be offended because these stories are real humdingers. Okay. Two truths and a lie with Joel McHale. Here we go. Two truths. And a lie. Here we go. I have been bitten by a bear. I have met Luciano Pavarotti when he was alive, obviously. I mean him after he died. And I quit drinking scotch.
其中一个是谎言。你得暂停，因为如果你讲三个25分钟的故事，我都得去嘘嘘了。我会生气的，因为这些故事真的是大部头。好吧。与乔尔·麦克海尔一起玩“两真一假”。我们开始吧。两真。一假。我们开始吧。我被熊咬过。我见过卢恰诺·帕瓦罗蒂，当然是在他活着的时候。我是说他在死后见了他。我戒了苏格兰威士忌。
Okay. Two truths and a lie. Oh, is it two truths? Two truths and a lie. Did she just give us two lies and one truth? Did you really? Okay, we're now playing two lies and one truth. I like that. I just saw you at a holiday party where I believe you were drinking scotch. And so I am asking myself, how recently did you stop drinking scotch? Were you not drinking scotch at that party? Were you not drinking an old-fashioned?
好的。两真一假。哦，这是两个真话吗？两真一假。她刚刚给了我们两个谎言和一个真话吗？你真的是吗？好吧，我们现在玩的是两个谎言和一个真话。我喜欢这个。我刚在一个节日派对上看到你，我当时相信你在喝苏格兰威士忌。所以我禁不住在想，你是什么时候戒掉苏格兰威士忌的？你当时在那场派对上没喝苏格兰威士忌吗？你当时没喝老式鸡尾酒吗？
I was drinking sparkling wine. Sparkling wine? You know, it wasn't a champagne. It was a prosaico. It was pro seco. You were? I was definitely not drinking a, definitely not drinking our old fashion. Okay.
我在喝起泡酒。起泡酒？你知道，那不是香槟。那是普洛赛克。那是普洛赛克。你当时在？我绝对没有喝，绝对没有喝我们的老式鸡尾酒。好吧。
I think in my entire lifetime, I have had maybe two old fashions. Wow. Jenna, you love an old fashion. Maybe you were drinking the old fashion. I was drinking an old fashioned. And so was Lee. And I thought, so were you? And so were the other fellows.
我想在我的一生中，我大概喝过两次老式鸡尾酒。哇。珍娜，你喜欢老式鸡尾酒。也许你当时在喝老式鸡尾酒。我当时在喝老式鸡尾酒。李也是。我想，你也是吗？其他几位也是。
I thought we were all toasting old fashions, but no. Clearly not. Prosecical. Okay. I choose the sparkling wine because if I can drink a lot, but if I start drinking hard alcohol publicly, people like, you go crazy? No, I will curl up. You can go night night?
我以为我们都在为老式鸡尾酒干杯，但并没有。显然没有。普洛赛克。好吧。我选起泡酒，因为如果我可以喝很多，但如果我开始在公共场合喝烈酒，人们就会问：你疯了吗？不，我会蜷缩起来。你可以直接去睡觉了吗？
You're like, I'm just going to sleep in the pool. I don't care where. I'm just going to lie down right here. Wait, so what was your other one? You got bit by a bear? Bit by a bear. and met Luciano Pavarotti. When he was alive, obviously.
你就像是：我要直接在泳池里睡着。我才不管在哪里呢。我只想直接躺在这里。等等，那你的另一个是什么？你被熊咬过？被熊咬过。还见过卢恰诺·帕瓦罗蒂。当然是在他活着的时候。
Because you guys know where I was born, right? Pacific Northwest. They're bears. Oh. What? Where were you born? Yeah. Now look up on Wikipedia where I was born. Oh, God. You're going to make me Google it right now. Don't tell me. I was born in Italy. So that's... You were born in Italy? Do you have Italian citizenship as well? Do you have dual citizenship? I could have had it. I was born before.
因为你们知道我是在哪里出生的，对吧？太平洋西北地区。那里有熊。哦。什么？你是在哪里出生的？对。现在在维基百科上查一下我是在哪里出生的。哦，天哪。你现在要让我用谷歌搜索它。别告诉我。我出生在意大利。所以那是……你出生在意大利？你也有意大利国籍吗？你有双重国籍吗？我本可以有的。我出生在……
for America recognized dual citizenship. You were born in Rome? Yeah. Aw. Your dad was the dean of students. Yes. At Loyola University Rome Center. My mom was a student.
美国承认双重国籍之前。你出生在罗马？是啊。啊。你爸爸是学生院长。是的。在罗马洛约拉大学中心。我妈妈是一名学生。
Scandal. How long did you live in Rome? Not long, but enough to meet Luciano Pabarotti, who was in his prime. And you were born in 1971. Well, what? Me too. Me too. Yes.
丑闻。你在罗马住了多久？没多久，但足够见到卢恰诺·帕瓦罗蒂了，当时他正处于鼎盛时期。你出生于1971年。好吧，什么？我也是。我也是。是的。
Yes. So that's the truth. The lies are that you've never been bitten by a bear and you still drink scotch, but not at public parties. Wait, how do we play this? Wait, we have to guess which is the truth. Oh, okay. Because you're playing two lies and the truth. I'm trying to think of which I'm not even sure now.
是的，那是真的。谎言是你从未被熊咬过，而且你还在喝苏格兰威士忌，只是不在公共派对上喝。等等，我们怎么玩这个？等等，我们必须猜哪个是真话。哦，好吧。因为你在玩两个谎言和一个真话。我正在努力想哪个是——我现在甚至都不确定了。
Okay. So, wait, you don't know which is your truth? No, I know what they are. Okay. So he did grow up, though, in the Pacific North. West. There could be bears, lady. Maybe he had a field trip and a bear bit him like when a monkey threw me on the ground in Indonesia. A monkey threw you on the ground? Yes, but we don't, we're not here to talk about that. We're not here to talk about that. Don't ask her about it. But I'm just saying,
好吧。所以，等等，你不知道哪个是你的真话？不，我知道它们是什么。好吧。所以他的确是在太平洋西北地区长大的。那里可能有熊，辣妈。也许他曾去过野外考察，然后一只熊咬了他，就像一只猴子在印度尼西亚把我按倒在地上一样。一只猴子把你按倒在地上？是的，但我们，我们不是来谈论这个的。我们不是来谈论这个的。不要问她这件事。但我的意思是，
you could have been on a field trip. Joel, don't. You do not. You know what? We don't here for so long. We will be here for a long time. Wait, but also he is on a show called Animal Control, with many animals. Yes. And now I'm worried that perhaps you have been bitten maybe by a bear. You're calling it a bear, but maybe it was a bear cub and maybe it was like a little love nibble. But I mean, a bear. When is the last time you heard of somebody being love nibbled by a bear?
你可能在参加野外考察时遇到过。乔尔，别这样。你才不会呢。你知道吗？我们不在这里待那么久。我们会在这里待很长时间。等等，但他也出演了一部名为《动物控制》的节目，里面有很多动物。是的。现在我开始担心，也许你真的被熊咬过。你叫它熊，但也许那只是一只小熊崽，也许就像是一个小小的爱的轻咬。但我的意思是，一熊。你上一次听说有人被熊爱的轻咬是什么时候？
A bear cub. A tiny bear. Do they have like, I don't know. Wait, do they have like puppy teeth that are real sharp and hurt? That's what I'm wondering. Okay. Well, I'm going to go with a truth is you met Poverati and that. That's it. There's only one tree. Oh, yeah. So that's it. I forgot the game. I think that's the game. Now, I know you have a very vast wine collection. Yes. And I feel like you might have a scotch every once in a while at home. Not in public. We know that because you'll go, you know, sleep in someone's yard. take their lemons. This is my guess as well.
小熊崽。一只小熊。它们的牙齿是不是很尖，真的很痛？这就是我在想的。好吧。嗯，我要猜真的事情是你见过帕瓦罗蒂，而且那个。就是这样。只有一个真的。哦，是的。所以就是这样。我忘了这个游戏。我想那就是游戏。现在，我知道你有很多藏酒。是的。我觉得你可能偶尔会在家里喝一杯苏格兰威士忌。不在公共场合。我们知道这一点，因为你会去，你知道的，睡在别人的院子里。拿走他们的柠檬。这也是我的猜测。
And so I think that's the truth. And I want to know if we're right. And then I want to hear the story. All right. I have not met Luciana Pavarovia. What? Oh, no. Now we have to pick between the other two.
所以我认为那是真的。我想知道我们是否猜对。然后我想听听这个故事。好吧。我没有见过卢恰诺·帕瓦罗蒂。什么？哦，不。现在我们必须在另外两个之间进行选择。
Wait, wait. He's not met. Huh. Okay. Notice how I walked you in. Do you want to be like, oh, I'll tie. You really walked us into it. I was born in Italy.
等等，等等。他没见过。嗯。注意到我是怎么把你们引入套的吗？你想说：哦，我扯平了。你真的把我们引入套了。我出生在意大利。
I know. It was the time. 1971. Joel, me thanks you've hosted game shows before. Welcome to a 1% club on Fox. Not making Kinscheon in Fox. Joel, have you been bitten by a bear? I was bit by a bear.
我知道。那是那个时代。1971年。乔尔，我感谢你以前主持过游戏节目。欢迎来到福克斯的1%俱乐部。不是在福克斯做宣传。乔尔，你被熊咬过吗？我被熊咬过。
You were! You were? Please tell the whole story. And I did not quit drinking scotch. Well, yes, okay. But I did not have an old-fashioned at that party. I stand corrected. Ironically, it was not on animal control. It was on the six-episode arc I had on the office,
你真的被咬过！你真的被咬过？请讲讲整个故事。我也没有戒掉苏格兰威士忌。好吧，是的，好吧。但我那次派对上没有喝老式鸡尾酒。我收回刚才的话。具有讽刺意味的是，那不是在《动物控制》里。那是在我客串《办公室》的六集戏里，
which I don't know why you didn't bring that up. What? There was no six-episode arc where you fight a bear. But you know what? I really wish you and Dwight were in the woods, whatever your character was. Maybe you're one of his cousins and you had to fight a bear. Oh, I did audition for Dwight.
我不知道你为什么没提这个。什么？没有六集的戏让你和熊搏斗。但你知道吗？我真的希望你和德怀特在树林里，无论你的角色是什么。也许你是他的表兄弟之一，你不得不和熊搏斗。哦，我去为德怀特试镜了。
You did? I did. Yeah. So it was the very, you know, going way back. And I was like, I probably should audition for, you know, Jim. And this is, you know, and then they were like, no, no, no, do I. And then I was like, I don't know. I don't know if I'm the right one for this one.
你试过？我试过。是的。所以那是，你知道的，追溯到很久以前。当时我想：我大概应该去为，你知道的，吉姆试镜。这是，你知道的，然后他们说：不，不，不，德怀特。然后我就想：我不知道。我不知道我是不是这个角色的合适人选。
And I didn't get past the, like, the initial read. And then when Rain got it, I was like, oh, yeah. Yeah. It couldn't be anybody else. Did you know Rain before? I knew. well, I knew of rain. Rain was already on his way to be. He was already a well-established comic and a local Seattle legend because he had done good. He had done good by then. So I think, what was that?
我甚至没有通过初读。然后当雷恩得到这个角色时，我心想：哦，是的。是的。除了他不可能有别人。你以前认识雷恩吗？我认识。嗯，我知道雷恩。雷恩已经在成名的路上。他已经是一位成熟的喜剧演员和西雅图的本地传奇人物，因为他成功了。那时他已经成功了。所以我想，那是什么？
Did you guys start in 2006? Three or four? Yeah. Yeah. That was, if it was three or four, then it would have been right as the soup was starting. Anyway, going way back. The soup. God, I remember watching the soup. I remember watching you on the soup like all the time. And then when I met you, I was like, awkward transition into the conversation. Do you have any lemons? Fancy finding you buy some lemons. Angela Kinsey's trying to steal lemons from us. Are we ever going to hear about this bear attack? Please. What do I need to do? I need to hear the story of the bear attack. It was so for a show called The Great Indoors, which was on CBS for one season in 2016. It was me, the great Stephen Fry, Christmonds, Plas, Christine Coe, Deborah Baker Jr. and
你们是2006年开始的吗？三四年的样子？是的。是的。那是，如果是三四年，那应该正好是《The Soup》开播的时候。不管怎样，追溯到很久以前。The Soup。天哪，我记得看《The Soup》。我记得我一直都在看你主持的《The Soup》。然后当我见到你时，我心想：这转折进对话真尴尬。你们有柠檬吗？真巧在这里碰见你们买柠檬。安吉拉·金斯利正试图偷我们的柠檬。我们还能听到这个关于熊袭击的故事吗？求你了。我需要做什么？我需要听听熊袭击的故事。那是为了一部名为《大室内》的节目，该节目于2016年在CBS播出了一季。主演有我、伟大的斯蒂芬·弗莱、克里斯·蒙兹·普拉斯、克里斯汀·高、黛博拉·贝克尔·小
Sean Brown. And Stephen Fry and I, he played my boss. Anyway, we did this scene with a bear cub. I had to hold the bear cub while I gave a speech. And they were like, okay, so the bear will probably become impatient. You got about 40 seconds. Because the bear doesn't really like to be held. And so you're holding the bear, and the bear's cuddly. It's a bear cub. It weighs 50 pounds. And you're holding this bear, and I start giving this speech as fast as I can.
和肖恩·布朗。斯蒂芬·弗莱和我，他扮演我的老板。不管怎样，我们和一只小熊崽拍了这场戏。我得抱着一只小熊崽，同时发表一段演讲。他们说：好吧，所以这只熊可能会变得不耐烦。你大概有40秒的时间。因为熊其实不喜欢被人抱。所以你抱着熊，熊很可爱。这是一只小熊崽。它有50磅重。你抱着这只熊，我以最快的速度开始演讲。
And then they were like, he'll just be annoyed. And he might bite you just to test things out. So I was wearing like three layers. And that thing bit me in the arm. And that thing, that beautiful thing. And so bears do not have sharp teeth. they have teeth that crush things. Oh no.
然后他们说：他只会感到恼火。他可能会咬你一口来试探一下。所以我当时穿了大约三层衣服。那个小家伙咬了我的胳膊。那个小家伙，那个美丽的小家伙。所以熊没有锋利的牙齿。它们的牙齿能把东西压碎。哦，不。
Not like a puppy at all. It just squeezes so hard because it's like they crush bones with them. So it didn't break skin, but it left this gigantic mouth-shaped bruise on my arm. So then I dropped the bear out of pain. Sure. And the bear didn't, the guy was like, oh yeah, the bear falls out of trees all the time, like three feet.
一点也不像小狗。它只是用力一夹，因为就像它们用牙齿压碎骨头一样。所以它没有咬破皮肤，但它在我的胳膊上留下了这个巨大的、嘴巴形状的淤青。所以由于疼痛，我把熊给扔了。当然。那只熊没有，那家伙说：哦，是的，熊经常从树上掉下来，大概三英尺高。
You can't, he was like, you'll not, this is nothing. He's never been happier. And then Stephen Fry had to pick him up and hold him and give a speech. And the exact same thing happened. So anyway. Was it just the one take, though? They weren't like, can you go again? We did one take.
你不会，他说：这没什么。他从来没有这么开心过。然后斯蒂芬·弗莱不得不把它抱起来并发表一段演讲。结果发生了完全一样的事。所以不管怎样。不过只有一个镜头吗？他们没有说：你能再来一次吗？我们拍了一条。
And they were, yeah, that was compared. They had river otters on set at one point. They wanted me to hold a river otter. And that was about 20 times more terrifying because they are big and they move so fast. And they were eating raw chicken and crushing the bones in their teeth. just like it's popular. And I'm like, the bear was just mellow and cool.
他们就，是的，那就是对比。他们有一次在片场有河狸。他们想让我抱一只河狸。那要可怕大约20倍，因为它们很大，而且动得太快了。它们在吃生鸡肉，用牙齿把骨头咬碎。就像这是流行的一样。而我觉得，熊只是随和而酷。
And the bear on the ground just walking around was like a nice dog. You know, I actually have a bear story. Oh. If you're interested. Yes. Okay, so I'm not sure if I've told this story on our podcast before,
那只在地上走来走去的熊就像一只好狗。你知道，我其实有一个关于熊的故事。哦。如果你感兴趣的话。好的。好吧，所以我不确定我以前是否在我们的播客中讲过这个故事，
but early in the office shoot, I think maybe I've mentioned it. They asked me and John and Rain to do a photo shoot. I think it was for TV guide. and for a reason I don't know, it was the three of us and a fully grown bear, like a full bear. And the bear was coming through the window. What? And then the three of us were like, ah.
但在《办公室》拍摄的早期，我想我可能提到过。他们让我、约翰和雷恩去拍一组照片。我想那是为《电视指南》拍的。出于我不知道的原因，我们三个人和一头成年的熊在一起，就像一头真正的熊。那头熊正从窗户钻进来。什么？然后我们三个人的反应是：啊。
And I have no memory of this lady. You can Google it, and I think you can find the image of us with this bear. And so they were kind of setting it up, and we were getting ready to go. And then someone came in and said, you know what? we've decided we're going to do these separate. So you guys just react as if the bear is there and then we'll bring the bear out later and we'll get the shot of the bear and we'll put them together. And we were like, that sounds good.
辣妈，我对此毫无记忆。你可以谷歌一下，我想你能找到我们和这头熊的合影。所以他们当时正在做准备，我们正准备开拍。然后有人进来宣布说：你知道吗？我们决定分开拍。所以你们就假装熊在那里做出反应，然后我们稍后把熊带出来，拍下熊的照片，然后把它们合成在一起。我们当时觉得：听起来不错。
I kid you not, a couple years later, I am pretty sure this is true. I don't want to disparage this bear if I'm wrong, but I think he killed his trainer. Oh my gosh. I think he killed someone. When you have a gigantic wild animal. Yeah. And so I'm so grateful that on the day, they decided to shoot us separately
我向你发誓，几年后，我很确定这是真的。我不想在如果我错了的情况下诋毁这头熊，但我认为他杀死了他的驯兽师。哦，天哪。我想他杀了一个人。当你养了一只巨大的野生动物时。是的。所以我非常感谢那天他们决定把我们分开拍摄，
because it turns out this bear, he had worked a long time, and I think he was done. He was grumpy. He wasn't into it anymore. He didn't want to be a performing bear. That bear may not even had intended to kill his, trainer. Right. It could have just been like, hey, and they just happened to have, you know,
因为事实证明这头熊，他已经工作了很长时间，我想他受够了。他很暴躁。他不再喜欢这样了。他不想再做一头表演熊了。那头熊甚至可能没有打算杀死他的驯兽师。对。可能只是像：嘿，然后他们碰巧有，你知道的，
their arm is a thousand times more powerful than a human arm. So then, right. I did a shoot with some monkeys, some chimpanzees, and I got there and it was for a magazine. And they were like, so don't look the monkeys in the eye. No, don't. And then I said, that's the rule. Then I, Yeah, then I literally was like, you shoot those guys separately because I'm not going to accidentally gaze at this thing and then it's going to come at me and kill me. Also, now you've told me don't look at the monkey in the eye and that's all I'm going to do. So that's what's in my brain now. I got to look him in the eye. I've got to see what happens.
它们的臂力比人类的胳膊强上一千倍。所以，没错。我跟一些猴子、黑猩猩拍过照，我到那儿的时候，那是为一本杂志拍的。他们就说，千万别盯着猴子的眼睛看。绝对不要。然后我说，这就是规则。然后我，对，然后我真的就想，你们单独拍那些家伙吧，因为我可不想一不小心跟这东西对视，然后它就冲过来把我给杀了。而且，现在你告诉我不要看猴子的眼睛，而这恰恰是我唯一想做的事。所以现在我脑子里想的全是这个。我非得跟他对视一下不可。我得看看会发生什么。
Julie, it seems like you've done a lot of television programs with animals because you are now in season four of animal control. I don't know how that worked out. But yeah, I worked with a ton of animals. I don't know how it all happened. I do love them. I love them to death. Like, I got to ride a camel this year down a residential street in Vancouver. And I was like, this is the greatest.
朱莉，你好像做过很多跟动物有关的电视节目，因为你现在正参演《动物控制》第四季。我不知道这是怎么促成的。不过，对，我跟大量的动物合作过。我也不知道这一切是怎么发生的。我确实很喜欢它们。我爱它们至深。比如，今年我竟然有机会在温哥华的一条住宅区街道上骑骆驼。当时我就觉得，这简直太棒了。
Can't believe this is happening. I have a question for you. Season 4, episode 1, animal control. There's a horse. It's going down the road. You jump out of a moving car, a slow moving car. and you kind of roll and then you jog up to the horse
简直不敢相信这居然发生了。我有个问题要问你。《动物控制》第四季第1集。里面有一匹马。它在路上走着。你从一辆正在行驶的车里跳了下来，是一辆慢速行驶的车。然后你顺势一滚，接着小跑着走向那匹马
and you mount it. Yes. That was not me. But did you fall out of the car? Because I believe you rolled out of the car but I'm like, I think the guy mounting the horse was not you because it's on your back and then we go to the front of you.
然后你骑了上去。没错。那个人不是我。但你是从车里掉下来的吗？因为我相信你是从车里滚出来的，但我想的是，那个骑上马的人肯定不是你，因为镜头先是在你背后，然后切到了你的正面。
And you are on the horse. But I just... What an opener. What a season opener. Yeah, we shut down a highway in Vancouver and we had like six hours, So we ran out there and got everything all set up and got in and got out and it worked. So they would not let me fall out of the truck, even though I'm one of those guys that believes I can prove that I'm going to live forever through physical accomplishments. So they were like, that's exactly why we're not allowing you to roll out of the truck.
而你已经在马上了。但我只是……多棒的一个开场啊。多棒的一季开场啊。对，我们在温哥华封锁了一条高速公路，我们大概只有六个小时的时间，所以我们冲过去，把所有东西都布置好，进去又出来，最后成功了。所以他们根本不让我从卡车上摔下来，尽管我就是那种坚信自己能通过身体上的成就来证明自己长生不老的人。所以他们就说，这正是我们不允许你从卡车上滚下来的原因。
So I had a bunch of pads on, so I did the last final roll. Okay. The only thing scary about that is there was a team of trucks all driving and they all had to be at a certain speed. So they're like, make sure you get up fast. You're going to get hit by this truck. Oh, my gosh. Great. And then the guy that did the horse thing, that jump.
所以我身上绑了一堆护具，最后那个滚是我自己做的。好吧。唯一让人害怕的是，当时有一队卡车都在开着，而且它们都必须保持一定的车速。所以他们说，你一定要赶快爬起来。你要是被这卡车给撞了。哦，天哪。太棒了。然后那个负责骑马的人，就是那个跳上马的动作。
I mean, I could not have done that jump because he grabbed the pommel and then he just flipped his legs up. And that dude is one of the greatest, like, horse trainers and performers on the planet. It was like an old-timey mounting of a horse. It was like in Ye Old West, how you might, like, run out into the field and just jump on the back of the horse. It was very cool. Thank you. Is there anything that you can tease for this season? Because now the two animal control units have merged. Is that going to be the main crux of the season? That is the main crux of the season. And everybody dies.
我是说，我可做不出那种动作，因为他抓住马鞍桥，然后双腿一翻就上去了。那家伙绝对是地球上最顶尖的驯马师和特技演员之一。那是一种老式的上马姿势。就像在古老的西部片里，你可能会，比如冲进田野里，然后直接跳到马背上。这真的很酷。谢谢。对于这一季，你有什么可以提前剧透的吗？因为现在两个动物控制小队合并了。这会是这一季的核心剧情吗？这确实是这一季的核心剧情。而且所有人都死了。
Stop it. Stop it. What happens in season? I don't know if you've seen Hamlet or the movie Hamnet. Okay. But yeah, there's a duel at the end. One of us is poisoned and then accidentally poisons the other. That's it. That's it.
住手。住手。这一季到底发生了什么？我不知道你有没有看过《哈姆雷特》或者电影《哈姆内特》。好吧。但确实，最后有一场决斗。我们其中一个人中毒了，然后又不小心把另一个人也毒死了。就是这样。就是这样。
It's like Hamlet and Red Wedding all at once. Oh, the Red Wedding, which I want Jenna to watch. I don't know why I find this hard to believe, but I feel like Fox is not letting the show end that way this year. I mean, Kyla Pratt and Jerry D. Who aim onto the show and boy, just knocking it out of the park. just so funny and just wonderful nemesis. Yeah, it's good times. It's Aaron now.
这简直就像《哈姆雷特》和血色婚礼的结合体。哦，血色婚礼，我真想让珍娜去看看。我不知道为什么我觉得这很难相信，但我总觉得福克斯今年不会让这部剧以这种方式大结局。我是说，卡拉·普拉特和乔尔·麦克海尔加盟了这部剧，天哪，简直是发挥得淋漓尽致。太搞笑了，而且是非常棒的死对头。对，时光很美好。现在是艾伦了。
I think we're almost to the season closer. And I do want to say this, you guys, that for folks that love the office, some of my favorite scenes, Joel, or when y'all are just all in the office, just giving each other a bunch of crap, you know? Like the animal control actual offices with the desks and the whole sort of vibe reminded me a lot of us in the bullpen of the office. So office fans, you want to check this show out. We literally said this should be like the office. It's the interpersonal relationships that all these guys have. And just keep zipping around those and we should be okay.
我想我们快要到季终集了。我真的很想说，大家伙儿，对于那些喜欢《办公室》的观众来说，乔尔，我最喜欢的一些场景，就是你们所有人都在办公室里，互相开各种无聊的玩笑，你知道吗？就像《动物控制》里真正的办公室，摆着办公桌，还有那种整体的氛围，让我想起了很多我们在《办公室》办公区里的情景。所以《办公室》的粉丝们，你们一定要看看这部剧。我们当时简直是直言不讳地说，这就该像《办公室》一样。正是所有人之间的这种人际关系。只要紧紧围绕着这些展开，我们就应该没问题。
I'm going to give you this. I think it's as if the office in Brooklyn 9-9 had a baby. Now I feel like you're lying to me because I can't take a compliment. And my imposter syndrome goes through the roof and even be compassionate. to those shows, it seems insane. So I'll take that. Well, it's a ton of fun and you guys are hilarious. And I love like just shooting the shit with you, Joel. You're such a just good person. It's my best business. We're so lucky. Yeah. Joel, thank you so much. I just adore you and I appreciate you. Well, come back on over and play some more tennis. You're welcome to come anytime.
我这么跟你说吧。我觉得这就好像是《办公室》和《神烦警探》生了个孩子。现在我觉得你在骗我，因为我根本承受不起这样的夸奖。我的冒名顶替综合征简直要爆表了，甚至都无法对那些剧集保持同理心，这听起来太疯狂了。所以，这份赞美我收下了。好吧，这真的超级有趣，你们也太搞笑了。我喜欢跟你一起瞎侃，乔尔。你真的是个特别好的人。这是我最好的生意。我们太幸运了。对。乔尔，太谢谢你了。我真的非常崇拜你，也很感激你。好啦，再来玩会儿网球吧。随时欢迎你来。
Thank you. I'll be there to eat the granola. And everyone else, we're going to take a break. and we're going to be back with Around the Town and the Office Question of the Week. All right. All the things I told were lies. No. Joel, you stinker. All right, bud. I'll talk to you soon. See you guys.
谢谢。我会去吃燕麦的。其他人，我们要休息一下。稍后我们将带来“走过小镇”以及“本周办公室问题”。好啦。我刚才说的全都是谎话。才没有。乔尔，你这个淘气鬼。好了，老兄。我们回聊。拜拜，各位。
Thank you. We are back. We are back from playing two lies and a truth with Joel McHale. I told you. I knew when I was like, you never know what you're going to get. We had no idea he was going to flip the script on us, but that was really fun. Well, could we get a little around? the town.
谢谢。我们回来了。我们结束了和乔尔·麦克海尔的“两句假话一句真话”游戏，现在回来了。我跟你说过。当我心里想“你永远不知道会碰上什么”的时候，我就知道了。我们根本没想到他会突然反客为主，但那真的太好玩了。好吧，我们能听听“走过小镇”的内容吗？
Our first news item comes from Don T. In Lytton, British Columbia, Don says, Hey, Angela and Jenna, I live in a very small Canadian town along the Fraser River, and we have a little two-car ferry that I have to go on to get across the river to get to work. Lately, there have been a lot of large ice chunks floating down the river, and this caused the paddle to break. So the ferry shut down for a while. But it's back and running as usual now. Wow, that's so wild to me. Just seeing huge chunks of
我们的第一条新闻来自英属哥伦比亚省利顿的唐·T。唐说，嗨，安吉拉和珍娜，我住在弗雷泽河畔一个非常小的加拿大城镇里，我们有一艘很小的双车位渡轮，我必须坐它过河去上班。最近，有大量巨大的浮冰顺流而下，这导致推进器坏了。所以渡轮停运了一段时间。不过现在它已经恢复正常运营了。哇，这对我来说太疯狂了。仅仅是看到巨大的冰块在漂浮？这太疯狂了。好吧，我们的下一条“走过小镇”来自圣路易斯的斯蒂芬妮·Z，珍娜。嗨，斯蒂芬妮。斯蒂芬妮说，这周为了情人节，我们去看了对我来说意义非凡的东西。有一个伟大的艺人，小丑猫王，他在城市博物馆以他自己的风格演唱了一组情歌。我看他的现场演出已经超过10年了，他是个当地的传奇人物。我第一次访问这座美丽的城市是在2021年，当时是为了看他的一场演出。在那之后的第二年，我又独自一人来这里看另一场，并在演出上遇到了我的伴侣，然后我在2022年搬到了这里。
ice floating? That's so wild. All right, our next around the town is from Stephanie Z and St. Louis, Jenna. Hi, Stephanie. Stephanie said, this week for Valentine's Day, we're seeing something very dear to my heart. There's a great entertainer, Clownvis Presley, playing a set of love songs in his style at the City Museum. I've been seeing his live shows for over 10 years. and he's a local legend. The first time I visited this beautiful city was in 2021 to see one of his shows. The year after that, I traveled here solo for another one, met my partner at a show, and then I moved here in 2022.
我们现在在南城拥有一栋迷人的小房子和五只可爱的猫。我们俩其实都不怎么庆祝这个节日，但它已经变成了我们可爱又怪异的小传统。晚上探索城市博物馆也真的超级有趣。斯蒂芬妮，这太酷了。我上次去圣路易斯的时候，我的家人，我们去了城市博物馆。安吉拉，那简直是我去过的最与众不同的地方。它有大约五层楼高，还有一个屋顶。
We now have a charming little house in South City and five adorable cats. Neither of us really celebrates this holiday too much, but it's become our cute-slash-weared little tradition. It's also really fun to explore the city museum at night. Stephanie, this is so cool. The last time I was in St. Louis, my family, we went to City Museum. Angela, it's like no place I've ever been. It's like five stories and a roof.
里面充满了洞穴、岩洞、狭窄的爬行空间，还有一个巨大的鲸鱼雕塑。你只要走遍所有地方，在所有地方爬来爬去就行了。但他们还有一个鱼缸，你可以把手伸进去，所有的鱼都会游过来，就像是在吃掉你手上的死皮一样。哦，天哪。这真是太酷、太独特了，而且我原本以为它不可能再独特了，但现在我听说这个过去的情人节他们居然请到了小丑猫王。我完全不知道。这个地方真的很酷。那真是太酷了。好了，我们的最后一条“走过小镇”来自宾夕法尼亚州韦恩的曼迪·L。曼迪说，我为我的侄女感到无比自豪。海登·A小姐在学校排演的
It is filled with caves and caverns and crawl spaces and a giant sculpture of a whale. And you just walk through all of it and climb through all of it. But then they also have this tank where you can put your hand in and all the fish come over and like eat the dead skin. in off your hand. Oh my goodness. It's so cool and unique and I didn't think it could get more unique, but now I'm hearing that this past Valentine's Day they had clownvis Presley. I had no idea. This place is really cool. That is so cool. Well, our last around the town comes from Mandy L. in Wayne, Pennsylvania. Mandy says, I'm just bursting with pride for my niece. Miss Hayden A has been cast as the role of Mrs. Herron in her school's rendition of
《贱女孩》音乐剧青少年版中被选为饰演海伦太太。这个角色最初由安娜·加斯蒂尔小姐塑造，最近在大银幕上由珍娜·费舍尔小姐饰演。祝海登·A小姐诸事顺利（断腿）。哦，海登，祝你饰演的海伦太太演出成功。我很喜欢扮演那个角色。那是个好角色。好吧，非常感谢大家发来“走过小镇”的投稿，现在我们要用本周的办公室问题来做个总结。
Mean Girls, Jr. The role was originated by Miss Anna Gastire and more recently played on the big screen by Miss Jenna Fisher, wishing many broken legs to Miss Hayden A. Oh, Hayden, break a leg as Mrs. Heron. I loved playing that part. It's a good part. Well, thank you so much for sending in your Around the Towns, and now we're going to wrap things up with our office question of the week.
这来自奥尔巴尼的克雷格·W。克雷格想知道，当演员们笑得停不下来时，谁才是房间里的大人？大家是如何从具有传染性的傻笑中恢复理智的？哦，克雷格。这是个好问题。哦，克雷格。我只能告诉你。那绝对不是我。
This comes from Craig W. in Albany. Craig wants to know who was the grown-up in the room when the cast lost it for too long. How was everyone brought back from contagious giggles? Oh, Craig. This is a good question. Oh, Craig. I can tell you what. It wasn't me.
这就是我能告诉你的。是谁把我们拉回严肃状态的？我绝对可以告诉你所有不是的人。那不是约翰·卡拉辛斯基。不是安吉拉。不是我。不是明迪。绝对不是明迪。
That's what I can tell you. Who brought us back to being serious? I can definitely tell you all the people it wasn't. It was not John Crosinski. It was not Angela. It was not me. It was not Mindy. It was definitely not Mindy.
绝对不是明迪。也许导演会介入并试图管束我们。偶尔我知道在会计部，当布赖恩和我笑个不停的时候，奥斯卡就会说，拜托，伙计们，行了。所以有时候是奥斯卡，但对啊，真的很难。要忍住不笑太难了。而且我们经常毁掉很多条拍摄。但这也是因为剧组人员。
Definitely not Mindy. Maybe a director would step in and try to wrangle us. Every once in while I know over in accounting when Brian and I would get the giggles, Oscar would be like, come on, guys, come on. So sometimes Oscar, but yeah, it was hard. It was really difficult not to laugh. And we often ruin many takes. But it was also the crew.
我是说，有时候你就能看到马特和兰德尔扛着摄像机在肩膀上直抖。或者特别是当你有一个像珍·萨拉达这样的编剧时，她自己就能毁掉无数条拍摄。不在镜头前。仅仅作为编剧制片人在镜头外。对。不过还有格雷格和保罗。对。我觉得就那些在镜头外会笑场然后把我们也带笑的人来说。
I mean, sometimes you could just see Matt and Randall kind of like shaking with the camera on their shoulder. Or especially if you had a writer like Jen Salada, she would ruin so many takes herself. Off camera. Just as the writer producer off camera. Yeah. And Greg, too, though, and Paul. Yeah. I feel like in terms of people who were off camera who would break and then get us going.
然后你就很难再恢复状态了，尤其是当你把镜头外的人也逗笑的时候。好吧，那才是最大的胜利，对吧？我记得有一次看到我们的收音师尼克·卡尔博尼拿收音杆的手都在发抖，因为他在笑。他的肩膀都在耸动。当时我就想，太棒了。但是，好吧。克雷格，非常感谢你的提问。
And then it's hard to come back from that, especially when you've made. made the off-camera people laugh, too. Well, that's the biggest win, right? I remember one time watching our boom operator, Nick Carbone's handshake as he held the boom because he was laughing. His shoulders were going. And I was like, yes. But, yeah. Well, Craig, thank you so much for your question.
这绝对让我脸上露出了笑容，想起了所有那些往事。但我想我们的答案是，导演们通常不得不把我们管束回来。而且偶尔，奥斯卡会压低声音说，拜托。而且也许，也许凯莉·坎特利能让我们收敛心神，对吧？对。我们的副导演。对。也许是凯莉。
It definitely brought a smile to my face, remembering all of that. But I guess our answer is, the directors usually had to rain us in. And every once in a while, Oscar, under his breath would be like, come on. And maybe, maybe Kelly Cantley could get us to pull it together, right? Yeah. Our AD. Yeah. Maybe Kelly.
我想是的。她有时会走过来然后说，伙计们，我们还想不想吃午饭了？赶紧拍吧。对。把饭提起来。那就能让我们变得严肃起来。女士们，你们还记得尼克·卡尔博尼加入我们之前的早期时候吗？甚至可能只是某个在片场纯粹充当额外人手的人。
I think so. She would sometimes come in and be like, guys, do we want to make it to lunch? Let's make it. Yeah. Bring up food. And that could get us to become serious. Lady, do you remember early on before Nick Carbone joined us? And it might have even been someone who was just on set as like an extra set of
当时有一个收音师，我们在大笑，而他被我们搞得超级心烦。你们还记得吗？那是在厨房里。我们在厨房里，我想我记得是哪一集，但我不想说具体是哪一集。我们当时都笑得前仰后合的，而他超级生气的，当时我就想，天哪，这工作可真不适合你。这其实是工作的一部分，我们在搞喜剧啊。我们有时就是会笑场，这也是能量的一部分。这也是一部分，而且我觉得他根本不像我们其他人那样觉得这剧好笑。我觉得他一点都不觉得好笑。对，确实。
hands. There was a boom operator and we were laughing and he got really annoyed with us. Do you remember that? It was in the kitchen. We were in the kitchen and I think I'm thinking of the episode, but I don't want to say what it is. And we were all busting up laughing and he got super annoyed and I thought, man, this is not the job for you. Like, this is part of it. Like we're making comedy here. We're going to break sometimes and that's part of the energy. And that's part of the and I think he didn't find the show as funny as the rest of us. I don't think he thought it was funny. Yeah, I do.
我还记得他，但没错，我们的剧不适合他。确实不适合。他应该去拍正剧，拍点更严肃的东西。律政剧或者罪案剧之类的，对。他可不怎么喜欢。不过听着，我是说，拍喜剧本来就是这样。我觉得这也是我学到的一点，那就是拍喜剧的氛围就是喜剧化的。如果你变得太严肃，
I remember him, but yeah, our show wasn't for him. It wasn't. He needed to be on a drama, something more serious. A procedural, yeah. He wasn't loving it. But listen, I mean, that comes with the territory on a comedy. I feel like that's something that I learned, too, is that the atmosphere of making a comedy is comedic. And if you get too serious,
或者你只是不停地看表，心想我们什么时候才能拍完这个镜头？其实这对我们的第一副导演凯莉和鲁斯蒂来说是个很难的角色，因为他们必须在片场留出轻松搞怪的时间，才能让喜剧的火花继续飞舞。但你还得确保能拍到镜头，并且我们能在吃午饭前收工
or you're just constantly looking at the clock and you're like wondering when are we going to get this shot? Like that's actually a hard role for our first ADs, for Kelly and for Rusty, because they have to leave time for the levity on set to keep the comedy ball in the air. But you also have to make sure you're getting the shot and that we're breaking in time for lunch
诸如此类的事情。所以我们在凯莉和鲁斯蒂身上真的很幸运，因为他们让我们尽情玩乐，但当需要的时候，他们也非常擅长把我们管束回来。对，他们就像是你那些有趣的叔叔阿姨，你知道的，既让你放飞自我，然后又会说，好啦，伙计们，行了，我们走吧。对。不能睡太晚。
and all that kind of stuff. And so we were really lucky with Kelly and Rusty because they let us have fun, but they were pretty good at, like, raining us in when they needed to as well. Yeah, they were like your fun aunt and uncle, you know, that let you, like, just let loose, but then it was like, all right, guys, come on, let's go. Yeah. You can't stay up too late.
睡前不能吃太多糖果。没错。嗯哼。对，有时候我笑得最厉害，其实正是在那些停顿的时候。我不知道你还记不记得，珍娜，但有太多次我们在会议室里，史蒂夫饰演迈克尔开始即兴发挥。所以我们根本不知道他接下来要说什么。剧本上的场景我们已经排练很多次了。然后总会有一两次
Can't eat too much candy before bed. That's right. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Some of the times I laugh so hard, too, was just in the pauses. I don't know if you remember that, Jenna, but there were so many times when we were in a conference room and Steve as Michael would start improvising. So we didn't know what he was about to say. We'd already gotten the scene scripted many times. And then there'd be one or two moments where
史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔有一串他必须说的话，而他开始即兴发挥那一长串台词。正是在他说下一句话之前的那个停顿，让我彻底破防了。他接下来要说什么的悬念对我有致命的吸引力。然后不可避免地，无论他说什么都会荒谬绝伦的好笑，但真正让我笑场的是那个停顿。就像他那长长的，我就想，哦天哪，我不行了。我不行了。所有这些回忆，天哪，我们以前真的笑得太多了。我们的工作居然是去一个地方，和搞笑的人在一起做搞笑的事，这简直是天赐的礼物。真的没有什么能与之相比。确实如此。我们真的很幸运。好啦，你们大家，非常感谢。希望你们喜欢这一集。非常感谢
Steve as Michael would have a list of things he had to say and he would start improvising that list. And it was the pause before he said the next thing where I would come undone. The excitement of what he was going to say was so thrilling to me. And then inevitably, whatever he would, said would be ridiculously funny, but it was the pause that got me. Like his long, like, I'm like, oh my God, I'm out. I'm out. All of this reminiscing about this is just, gosh, we laughed a lot. What a gift that our job was to go somewhere and be around funny people being funny. There's just nothing like it. Truly. We're really lucky. Yeah. Oh, you guys, thank you so much. We hope you enjoyed this episode. Big thank you.
乔尔·麦克海尔跟我们一起度过了一个充满滑稽的下午。也谢谢所有发来闲聊和“走过小镇”投稿的每一个人。我们太喜欢听你们分享了。我们非常感激这个社区。以防万一，这些小猫现在还在我的家里，各位。请登录 kittenrescue.org 领养我的小猫吧。没错，快来领养可爱的小猫。好啦，各位，祝你们度过愉快的一周。我们下期再见。回头见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）出品的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。
to Joel McHale for spending the afternoon with us being silly. And thank you to everyone who sends in their chit chats and around the towns. We love hearing from you guys so much. We appreciate this community so very much. And just in case, these kittens are still in my house, everybody. Please go to kittenrescue.org and adopt my kittens. Yes, adoption of sweet kittens. All right, you guys, have a great week. We'll see you next time. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《鲁珀特之树》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Odyssey》的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《Office Ladies》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《鲁珀特树》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。